why you're gonna have to use a
combination of these and the twine that
they sell we've been looking to fix the
camera room up for a while it's a little
chaotic in there with lifeline
approaching and all these other projects
approaching this fall I think both Nico
and I got a B in our bonnet to get this
done
I'm sending Derek and Brett off to Home
Depot the problem is they don't have a
truck and I need them to get 81 feet of
wood I'm going to take Nick's car today
the what the Hampton will be able to
move what's the hamster mobile warp on
cotton I'm star it's the same car in the
Hampshire commercials it's not the car
from the hamster commercial hipsters
were a party so good luck I heard only
one out two people ever make it out
alive
yeah man either way you've got
so you are probably familiar with the
HTC pod which is the virtual reality
headset valve we do a lot of VR gameplay
on note you know the gaming channel and
I'm a part of a family person playing
the game and we show the perspective in
the game and that's it so how cool would
it be to actually film them as if
they're in the game we actually film the
person in that world almost like how
James Cameron filmed avatar we'd have a
camera and then be tracked and you see a
real-time visualization of that world
from a handy-dandy aperture lights
[Music]
basically this will mount here that will
be else works let me take out which
controllers controlling camera it's not
that one it's not that one it's this one
these two should come my hands well that
works it works great thing is gonna rock
around
about 60% of shangri-la or over majority
Jenny so basically now the next thing
you do is I need to calibrate the
program so that this position in the
position the camera itself are in the
right spot
note the list yes don't you have the
list analyst Jake give you the list
Jake denies this huh what is it she gave
me the credit card
it was for the credit cards I got the
list
oh my god my main concern is that we're
not going to be able to fit in all the
bins into the car we're gonna have to
make two trips my biggest concern is why
do you own this bill three of you is
this joy mu hell if you're angry no you
are you it is your ex Merry Christmas
Karishma Eve is 1914 all the world war
on metal file
[Applause]
do not buy me and start this one right
here it's its joy to all it says arrival
of I don't Merry Christmas
well I read that well that's what Merry
Christmas means joy to all right now the
field of view is just a little too wide
and the positions just limit off first
let's move the screen screen Nick
exterior
so now we're oriented with the game
better yeah cuz the game faces this way
so you're fighting over here the field
of view that alright probably my screen
if you see both patrollers right think
it's working late
[Music]
we found the wood yep it's right there
the common board he's just about to cut
them now and have those ready so we
think Derek what I was listening so
you're doing angry about all forget some
storage boxes for storage holy oh yeah
I'm click to find storage boxes
[Music]
[Applause]
solid
it's nice yeah it's not going anywhere
yeah good job guys
anyone named Joey Joey ladies is gonna
turn the final destination so quick yes
and they're more or less than entered
screen right there
all right what's up what's going on mix
yeah
what what do you call reality mmm
there's virtual reality what are we in
right now
meet space meet space we're in the meat
space yeah so I'm not getting proper
alpha channels in the top and bottom but
I think it's okay
great and you want to play a little
space pirate trainer okay yeah yeah I'm
ready okay hold still burn we're set the
name
[Music]
all right sorry game
should work out where your guns and
stuff in depth
[Music]
here's how you doing
I have the gameplay footage with all the
crazy quadrants that I was recording in
I need to seek that with my camera
footage I recorded when I started
recording game boy bang
it was so you see him criss-crossing his
guns
boom
synched lot randomly here I should be
able to keep him out and he'll appear to
be on the background there we go
it's almost working
that is pretty that's pretty cool that
is whoa what that's pretty hey it works
I raise impressed but I'm not done yet
guys I'm not done yet it's a foregone
lair being recorded also here's
reduction lasers
that's really cool
[Music]
you